one of the things that troubles me about
the discussion and I really like to move
to human animal comparison is that we're
at the top end of the story what's good
what's right and so on we have pretty
clear ideas of what you know George Bush
might have called evil certainly when
someone tortures another for some
personal value some personal good we
recognize that something fundamentally
wrong with that when I have many
colleagues that have studied primates
particularly chimpanzees and have now
seen a number of films videos taken
where chimpanzees have torn other
chimpanzees limb from limb while they're
alive
in just killing them in this process and
they do this of course when they kill
monkeys for food it's a horrific thing
to watch because I'm inside that
monkey's head that's getting torn apart
I get the suffering I can in a sense
though I don't suffer myself I can
anticipate what that suffering is and I
think the suffering piece is right we as
human beings looking at this I don't
think that this chimpanzee is morally
corrupt because he's done this but if I
saw a human being doing that especially
in adults of young children maybe not
especially adult I would find something
terribly repulsive about this and what
it is is that I recognize that that
adult can get inside the head of
somebody else can in a sense interest
subjectively get a sense of what's going
on anticipated and when someone tortures
someone else it's because they can do
that because they can read not so I like
to think about you know that one of the
greatest gifts we have is to be able to
get inside at each other's head it's
sort of using this greatest gift we've
been given that other species don't have
against other species it's a remarkably
horrific thing to watch and to think
about and one of things that I think at
the bottom end of things we have to talk
about the good and the stuff I think we
can be pretty clear about what's at the
bottom end what we say no and if we have
some pretty clear understanding
that I think it's a good hint to move
our way up why it is that we don't hold
four-year-olds responsible for murder
even if they've killed somebody why we
don't hold people who are mentally ill
schizophrenic and thinking that somebody
else is a demon of why you don't hold
them responsible and I think it has to
do with a reasoning issue are you sure
that you're not when you see somebody
being torn limb from limb come which is
it that you are empathetic with them and
how much is that you're worried that
you're gonna be the next one that gets
torn limb from limb if that kind of
behavior is allowed to persist well I
admire you if it's the former I'm not
talking about beautiful I'm not talking
about people I'm talking about watching
an animal you're twirling from them who
said what would how you would feel to
some human being no it's yes it's it's
imagining myself in that okay okay for
what Rebecca and I agree on is the
amazing and Richard the amazing moral
improvement that we've seen and that is
it comes from empathy it comes from
recognizing that other people are like
myself and where does that come from
well I think that made why has it gotten
better it may be simply because people
are more illiterate and we go we go to
the movies and we see people living
lives I think the the image of of Sidney
Poitier behaving in a way that we would
recognize we might behave in movies for
example tremendous effect in improving
race relations in this country just
simply we were exposed to other people
in literature and newspapers and movies
and and so we improved in our pay and
our treatment of them I want to do go
back to what Pritzker said about
haziness I agree I think that moral
judgments are irreducibly hazy and I
don't see anything wrong with that I
don't see any reason for saying I'm not
I distrust morality
and I think aesthetic judgments are also
irreducibly hazy so what I think not
everything is mathematics and we have to
live with them
morality which cannot be reduced to
rational judgment I still insist I am
delighted to find an issue on which I
seem to disagree with other people here
because I was afraid that what I was
saying would be so completely obvious to
everyone it would be a waste of time but
I I continue to take the example of
vengeance which someone mentioned in
passing should we in addition to
deterrence or just putting people away
so they can't continue their crimes
should we also exert vengeance on people
who do evil things I think so you know I
don't well vengeance is not personal I'm
not I'm yeah all right I don't I don't
want to argue yes yeah I think I think
people who do evil things should be
punished and unhappy if they are and it
has nothing to do with the parents or
reforming them or anything else
I think Hitler's you know unfortunately
he put himself outside the reach of
punishment but I think Hitler should be
punished because he's evil this comes
back to the question about free will and
so on the fact that we if we lived in a
deterministic universe or in a universe
where determinism is qualified by the
randomness in quantum mechanics I would
still say Hitler should be punished
because he's evil doesn't matter why he
became evil you know maybe because his
father beat him I don't care he's evil
laziness was that was there a haziness
to his evilness from your perspective no
but I think there is a haziness in
balancing this kind of judgment with
other judgments there may be for example
Prudential arguments for not going out
and punishing people who do evil things
depending on how evil it is and there's
an irreducible haziness in trading off
one value against another value we have
no way I claim of calculating for
example how much of society's resources
should go into punishing evil people but
what is evil and what's not
well even there there might be but but
Hitler is clearly cross that line yeah I
mean everyone uses that line for you
perhaps yeah be careful not to treat
ourselves as models of people generally
right because because yes we recently
self-consciously reflect on this
amendment I think of a simple example
with respect to this moral progress
stuff so when I was a kid when I was a
child my parents thought that gay people
were worse than criminals right they
basically thought gay people should not
it was just an instinctive judgment they
did not think gay people should be able
to participate in society at all um well
now my parents aren't still alive and
they have gay friends they conventional
liberal morality about gay people and
this Freudian this process happened very
very slowly I don't think they ever
really thought about it much at all
right that is we're all in a state all
the time of kind of indoctrinating each
other in coordinating and that the
targets are the circumstances under
which we do this coordination are
themselves socially evolving so there
was no magic line like we know there was
no day on which my parents had United
attitudes towards gays and then
enlightened attitudes towards gays they
just broaden they just they just changed
and that's what we're all that's what
all people are do
all the time of course it's no surprise
in light of that that we should see this
kind of dramatic moral change over the
last couple of hundred years because of
course the wider economic and political
circumstances of people have changed for
much much more faster and much much more
dramatically since the Industrial
Revolution that he ever did before
so people in 1700 didn't live all that
differently from people in 1300 but
people in and in in 2012 looked very
differently indeed from people in 1912
you